I don't ask myself do I have the time
for that because it's really easy to
cheat instead I started to ask myself
two questions the first one is do I want
to use my energy for that my finite
amount of energy that I've got do I want
to use it for that and secondly given
that I don't have a lot of empty space
in my life where I don't know what to do
with myself
I have to ask myself if I'm going to
take on that project what am I going to
do less of
I'm joined by Gayle golden Gayle welcome
to the show
I'm delighted to be here very good to
have you here talking about work-life
balance today 21st century I think a lot
of people listening will understand when
work starts to creep into life right the
barrier gets blurred between what you're
supposed to do by day and what you want
to do by evening so your background the
things that you do the people you've
worked with what are the common problems
that you see people encountering with
the work-life balance you know it's a
great question so very quickly my
background is that for the first half of
my career I worked as a psychotherapist
work with with all different kinds of
people who were struggling with various
sorts of psychological and emotional and
relationship problems in their lives
mid-career I decided I was ready to do
something different so I went back to
school got my MBA and since then I've
been working with executive coaching and
business leadership and different kinds
of people with different kinds of issues
the thing that began to dawn on me was
that although these two kinds of work
and two populations were very different
there was a problem that crossed over
those two populations which was that
almost everybody almost all the time
felt overwhelmed exhausted inadequate
and as if they were not meeting their
own or other people's expectations
whether you were the senior executive of
a global fortune 500 company or whether
you were a stay-at-home parent hanging
around with little children that same
theme kept coming up and meanwhile we've
been talking about work-life balance
forever and I thought wait a minute
something is not working here this
concept of work-life balance I don't
know anybody who has a balanced life
myself included and then we somehow
imagined that other people do and that
just makes us feel even more in adequate
and overwhelmed than out of control
maybe it's time to start thinking about
this problem in a
way I loved your analogy in the book
where you were talking about how you
always look at other people like they've
got it together you know I think you
were talking about someone that was
learning to play the guitar and there
was a PhD student and did this and had a
family and was altruistic weekend
weekend endurance athlete all that stuff
and from your view he had it together
and the the the mother of five who had
seven dogs and and parachutes on a
weekend she had it together and
everything else but internally
everyone's just a chaotic mess and I
think this asymmetry between what we see
of other people and what we see of
ourselves is one of the big explanations
for why we often feel inadequate right
you only get to see the highlight reel
of everyone else but you get to see your
own blunders from the front-row seat
that is so true that the phrase that I
often use is don't compare your own
insights to other people's outsides and
we do that all the time and I'll tell
you one of the the big realizations for
me was as I was doing that looking at
the people the kinds of people you're
describing and thinking oh my gosh you
know they're so amazing
and then one day I began to realize that
there were people who were looking at me
as if I was one of those people who
would had it all together and was doing
it all and I thought my god don't they
know what a trainwreck I am doing
sometimes I go I gotta get to work and I
find I haven't got any pants on you know
like I'm faking it half the time you
know all of this stuff and but that made
me think well okay if other people think
that's my life then I'm probably
mistaken about those other people who
seem to have it all together and that
got me thinking that about okay how
could we really move towards a life that
felt more more meaningful more focused
more using my energy for the things that
really matter and that's what I started
to work on you touched on a key word
that energy
what was the book that you suggested
that you said started your journey I
can't remember it absolutely it's a
wonderful book I recommend it to almost
every one of my clients it's called the
power of full engagement by two guys
lower and Schwartz and these two guys
started out they were athletic coaches
who were specializing in working with
athletes who had fallen off their peak
performance they were not able to
perform at the level they previously had
been able to reach so the question was
what's going on with these people they
clearly have the capacity why are they
not performing at that level and out of
that work they developed some principles
which they then began to apply to the
people they call corporate athletes
high-profile
leaders in high-stress jobs and one of
their key what recommendations one of
their their key findings was don't talk
about managing time you can't manage
time you get 24 hours a day there's
nothing you could do about it it just
keeps coming so it's not useful to think
about managing time instead start
thinking about managing energy and how
do I want to utilize my energy and for
me that was a very powerful message
because it changed the question for me
if somebody comes to me and says hey
Gail we'd like you to work on this
project we think you'd be great will you
do it I don't ask myself do I have the
time for that because it's really easy
to cheat and say oh yeah yeah you know
I'm free between 2:00 and 2:30 in the
morning so I can do that you know
instead I started to ask myself two
questions the first one is do I want to
use my energy for that my finite amount
of energy that I've got do I want to use
it for that and secondly given that I
don't have a lot of empty space in my
life where I don't know what to do with
myself
I have to ask myself if I'm going to
take on that project what am I going to
do less off and if I can't come up with
an honest answer to that then I can't
take on the project and so those two
questions do I want to use my energy for
that and if I do what am I going to do
less of it's really a good way of not
turning myself into that overcommitted
frenzied person who feels so out of
control right I couldn't agree more the
number of times where I've just said yes
to things because I want novelty because
it sounds like an adventure because it
sounds like something that might be fun
or interesting or different or I
explained it away as hedging not all of
this this is me playing the field it's
gonna I'm distributing my portfolio more
effectively or it's multiple revenue
streams man or whatever it might be
right all the different ways all the
different ways that it comes through we
recently had great Greg McEwan author of
essentialist on the podcast and I think
a lot of your ideas and his align which
is that you need to focus on the vital
few and not the trivial many but as
you've identified we just like the idea
of new and it's easier to say yes then
it's weird that it's easier to commit to
doing a thing than to say no because
doing the thing actually involves a
state change it's easier to say yeah
I'll do I'll take the kids to school
I'll do the dog walk I'll add this
project in yeah I'll do the presentation
it's weird isn't it yeah well yes and
look I think I think this is a simple
idea which is very complicated to make
it work in your life and that is another
one of my basic principles is that you
know we're not talking about simple
problems simple problems people fix
those these are complicated difficult
issues saying no I mean what makes that
so hard
first of all as you say sometimes the
thing looks really exciting and
unappealing and and delightful in and
yeah I'd love to do that in the same way
that a museum curator who is putting
together a good exhibit which is the
analogy that I used throughout my book
that curator has all kinds of beautiful
works of art that they could put into
the exhibit but most of them aren't
going to fit and so finding a way to say
yeah you know that's a great Rembrandt
but it doesn't belong in my van Gogh
exhibit you know that that's that that's
the challenge that we have so it's it's
both our own desire for all these things
it's also our inner voice that says
hello what's the matter with you other
people can manage to get all of this
done you should be able to do it as well
and then there's the fact we don't want
to disappoint other people we don't want
to let people down we don't want to have
people not like us and so that's another
piece I think that makes it hard to say
no that's such a good framing now those
those last two are really really
important the fact that you don't let
other people down and also that you see
other people being able to get stuff
done you presume that you will up
regulate your productivity or down
regulate your sleep as appropriate to
fit stuff in right it just is it and
I've done it for years and years and
years because you see your own
inefficiencies on that front row see and
you're like yes I spend 45 minutes a day
on YouTube or Instagram or whatever all
I need to do is say yes to the project
and get rid of the Instagram any like
that you need to start from where you
are with regards to your efficiency not
where you think that you could get to if
you added this thing in and this is
Chris sparks past modern wisdom podcast
cast as a strategy very similar to yours
which is in order to pick something up
you have to put something down
absolutely
what you're talking about actually feeds
right into the other one of my very
favorite learnings from their power of
full engagement when they studied these
athletes what they found is the most
highly productive high achieving people
have a rhythm where they manage their
energy that is sprint and recover sprint
means you do something full force you
work at it as hard as you can whether
it's a physical activity or a mental
activity or putting on the best podcast
you can possibly figure out how to do
you do that with everything you've got
for a defined period of time
and then you stop and recover and rest
and that that's how highly productive
people get things done meanwhile we live
in a society that says oh I've worked
24/7 I never have to take a break I run
run run run run run run until I drop and
that's a recipe for inefficiency so
going back to your idea about I'm
spending 45 minutes a day looking in at
you - you have to you need that
that's your recovery time if you don't
do that you're going to be less
productive so instead of doing it and
feeling guilty about it you say okay I'm
gonna work hard for 90 minutes two hours
and then I'm gonna go look at YouTube
for 1530 minutes get my recovery to get
my break and then come back and work
again that's how people get it done
looking at how Newports deep work I
think he found in that that even the
absolute peak performers of knowledge
work could squeeze out top top end four
to six hours of focus deep work per day
right right what does my say what does
it tell us that the average work and the
full-time workers at work for eight
hours I don't say well I mean it
certainly says we aren't going to be
spending all of those eight hours doing
that that deep work that you're talking
about people just can't or don't the
same as you know somebody who's a mean
hockey players when they play hockey
they're not on the ice all the time they
skate like Mad Men and then they go off
for a few months and then they come to
0-2 they're rotating him in and out all
the time
that's the model that we need to learn
to use now that doesn't mean that in
your 8 hours at work you're not doing
other productive kinds of work or
connecting with coworkers you know
making relationships that lead to
collaboration and creativity just
spending a little time reflecting doing
the doodle work that has to get done as
part of any workplace that the
low-intensity work so it doesn't mean
that you know for for that you know for
this is six hours a day you're doing
nothing at work but you won't be doing
deep work the whole time that's for 100%
sure I get it ok so we're gonna do a
work/life balance MOT why do we where do
we start
first you have to tell me what you what
do you weigh moti oh god I forget that
you're right so it's when he take your
car in for a service it's just why are
we beginning we need to frame the fact
that someone has terrible work-life
balance how do they how do they know how
do they know why do they stop right okay
sorry about that not too much anger
sizing everything you know I believe
that America doesn't have mo T's well
you know what it means something
entirely different in the United States
and that's why I saw it I probably
should ask I don't know I don't know
what it is it's very terrible but it's
very different oftentimes members of the
Jewish community will use the phrase mot
which means member of the tribe and it's
a way of identifying other jews imagine
if you took imagine if you took your car
in and you I really want to I need to
get my car sorted would you be able to
give it an MOT and then you come back
and there's just someone Jewish sat
there that was like hey I'm your new
friend
know where we are serviced we are doing
a work/life balance
service okay so as I say it's not hard
to identify when it's out of whack you
feel bad you feel lousy you feel
inadequate you feel like everybody else
is doing more than you're doing that
something is not right about your life
and by the way your suggestion that we
do this to ourselves all the time we say
oh yeah I can sleep less really bad idea
really bad idea both psychologically and
physically a recipe for breakdown so not
a good idea so you start with that
discomfort I'm you know this is not
working for me and then my curating
model says that the first thing you have
to do is to figure out what is your
exhibit about okay what is this exhibit
you're trying to design what's it about
at this particular time in your life
what matters to you what are you
passionate about what what do you
focused on or what should you be focused
on and that of course changes over your
lifetime your exhibit at 25 is going to
be probably quite different from when
seventy-five but you need to do that
work to sort of understand what are the
things that really matter and this is
very individual and customized and I was
just talking with a woman this morning
for whom one of the main things her
exhibited is about right now is making a
lot of money she's the main earner in
her family she's got two young children
and she wants to put our energy into a
place that is going to make a lot of
money that sets her family up to be
comfortable from now on that might or
might not be what drives you or what
drives me but for her that's what her
exhibit is about right now and she then
should make choices based on that value
that importance for her somebody else
their exhibit might be about I don't
know how can I work towards better
visual equity in the United States which
is a very big issue for us right now for
that person they need to then organize
their exhibit differently so from number
one it's what my exhibit is about and
then just like a museum curator you look
around it all the stuff you couldn't be
putting in written in your exhibit or
you have been putting in your exhibit
and you see that it's kind of a
cluttered mess if you put all that stuff
in so you have to start making decisions
about what doesn't go into your exhibit
and it doesn't mean it goes in the trash
it may mean that it gets put in the back
room for now but it's not going to be in
your exhibit right now I can give you an
example when I mentioned I went back to
school a mid-career and got my MBA for
two years I was going to school
full-time and running a private practice
full-time I had two full-time
commitments and so I had to do a couple
of things one was I went to my husband
and my one son who were still living at
home and said I can't cook for the next
two years how did that go dad went out
went on great my husband said fine I got
it you bought a microwave that's such a
bloke solution isn't it it's a terrific
solution and it
great and for those two years he did it
I also went to all my friends and said
I'm gonna be a social drama for the next
two years I I will not be able to hang
with you guys I love you I'll see you in
two years and that worked out fine with
everybody except one friend who was
really angry and said you know I must
not mean anything to you if that's how
you're gonna treat me and I lost that
friend and I'm and I'm sad about that
but frankly it was a it was a curation
that I had to do those were things I had
to eliminate from my life in order to do
the things that my exhibit was about
which were running my practice going to
school and trying not to completely
destroy my family in the process fact
that was it so number one what's your
exhibit about number two what am I not
going to do and then there's a whole
process for how you eliminate stuff
by saying no by delegating by you know
stepping back from things oh there's all
kinds of ways you can do that the next
step is for many people the most
difficult because these are the things
I'm gonna have them in my exhibit I have
to have them in but they're not the most
importantly so in the in using the
museum of idea they're off in the side
room somewhere if people really want to
look at those things they can go in but
it's not the focus of the exhibit in the
real-life parallel it means that I make
a conscious choice that I am going to do
those things just well enough what are
some examples of things like that that
tend to be in people's lives that that
you're gonna do just well enough well
again it varies from person to person I
mean everyone's exhibit is unique I can
tell you for my life pretty much my
whole life housework has gone into the
just well enough piece of my exhibit my
home is not immaculate my it's never
going to be on the cover of
Architectural Digest magazine if you
know it's not if you know nobody's
coming and condemned it yet but it's
it's it's you know what my attitude is
if it's visible I wanted to be
reasonably tidy if you open a closet
it's on you what joke
find I mean that's a good heuristic yeah
exactly you know it's just good enough
for somebody else for whom that really
matters that's part of their peace of
mind or part of their brand then they
should do that to perfection
but it's it's not part of my the most
important things in my exhibit in the
workplace it's harder to do this but
again we have to I would like to read
every professional journal in my
profession and be up to date on all the
research that has any relevance to my
work I don't I don't I believe two or
three journals most of the time it's
just good enough does that mean things
are gonna fall through the cracks yeah
sometimes there's going to be an
important article I'm gonna miss it
but that's what I have to do in order to
have the energy for the things I want to
be great at when I want to be
provocative
I call this embracing mediocrity because
it seems to me most of us have a
terribly hard time doing this because
we've absorbed these lessons that say
you know if you're gonna do something be
great at it you know the good is the and
the the good is the enemy of the great
you know well I say that good is the
friend of the great because the reality
is most of what we do in our life we do
mediocre we just do we don't have the
boundaries to be great at most of what
we do it's it's just good enough I don't
ever want to be great at doing the
housework my cleaner during lockdown my
cleaner hasn't been being able to come
and I'm I'm barely even competent by I'm
doing being being correct good being the
enemy of the great or the friend of the
great that's up for debate but I don't
think that anyone can debate that
perfect is the antithesis of progress if
we try and be perfect with everything
that we do we never take the product to
market as we're recording this only
yesterday I released my website for the
first time right and there's stuff on
there well I'm not all that animation
could be a little bit more of this there
are maybe I could have a slightly more
sophisticated tracking pixel up maybe
that logo if I sent it back off but I've
done this before
and
the mark of an unnaturally verdicts that
they don't realize that Minimum Viable
Product is what it says it is it is the
minimum to get it to market and then you
iterate from there it's like jumping and
learning to fly on the way down
obviously you can jump too early but I
think in my experience people are far
too prepared
to use their perfectionism as a a proxy
for procrastination that if they
continue to perfect on this thing and
iterate on the stuff that they know
doesn't matter they never actually have
to look at the stuff which does matter
that they're uncomfortable with people
are happy to do name generation
I'm sure you've fallen prey to this at
some point coming up with the name for a
management company or whatever it might
be
you'll do you'll do name generation
brainstorming take 8 hours of meetings
once a week for the next two months
right but then actually getting down to
the nitty-gritty of that right ok so
who's looking after clients and who's
looking after this and how are we going
to structure the blah blah blah that
people don't want to do that but they'll
play around with logos and names and
there's red there's people that are
listening that are cringing at the fact
that they've got a thing they want to do
they want to start a business a blog put
a blog a podcast or whatever and they've
been mincing over the the name or the
logo or the what it's something that
doesn't what type of webcam whatever it
might be and it's like isn't what people
care about and also isn't what brings
value so yeah I like the the good
facilitating the great yes yes exactly
you've made so many points just now that
I just totally want to agree with one of
the things I suggest is you have to look
at the ROI the return on investment you
know we can put 75 hours into creating a
logo with 10 high pay people in the room
like really what's the ROI on there it's
not so good for you right I can spend an
awful lot of time making my house
immaculately perfectly clean well you
know I charge a pretty good hourly fee
as a consultant those hours do I want to
be spending them you know with a
toothbrush scrubbing
underside of my bathroom sink or
something no you know so I think look
there are things where perfection or
close to it matter if you are mine
neurosurgeon and you are going to be
inside my brain I want you to be a
perfectionist I don't want you to be
saying when I went in right so I mean
there are places in life where
perfectionism really matters you're
you're the engineer and you're designing
a bridge that I'm gonna cross over you
know I want it to be 100 percent certain
that it's safe but as I said most of
what we do in our lives is just good
enough and then we waste energy feeling
bad about that instead of saying that's
my choice that's not where I'm putting
my best energy I'm just choosing to be
good enough in that stuff and then if
you do those two things you say no to
the things that you really don't want to
be doing in your life right now or maybe
you want to but they don't fit you let
yourself be good enough on all those
things we're good enough is good enough
you will have the energy for your
greatness for the things that are
important the things that are your
legacy the things that really matter to
you and you won't have to feel
inadequate and overwhelmed and exhausted
all the time because you'll have enough
energy for the things that really matter
and you'll hang those paintings front
and center in your exhibit where people
can see them that's the model the
satisfaction that you get from those
paintings right from the ones they're so
disproportionately more than if the
house was cleaner if you were a tiny if
you were 2% less body fat if you were
whatever it might be you know like the
fitness side of things is a an
interesting one um coming from the the
fitness industry myself I see so many
people who want multiple goals some of
which compete and almost all of which
can't be achieved at the same time so
this morning I was chatting to a buddy
Andrew and he was saying he was asking
about some stuff to do
diet because he wanted to be a little
bit leaner because of this but he's also
got like an ultramarathon
like endurance long-distance event that
he's got coming up plus he's on furlough
but about to go back to work and as I do
like just just pick your battle whatever
battle it is it doesn't matter but pick
it get get this race out of the way
crush the race and then get lean or get
yourself back to work nail work get into
your worker routine and then prep for
the race or then do you know what I mean
and that curate your life you rate your
life yeah you should have Gayle you
should have said it my video guy video
guy Dean the guy that will be editing
this very video I'm not even kidding you
an hour ago from now he sent me a video
title of the video
what is work-life balance and I was like
dude search the title of the the lady
that I'm about to podcast with and
search what the subtitle of that book is
curating your life ending the struggle
for work-life balance and he was like
that's so freaky so but this isn't
serendipity this isn't coincidence
this is like sheer volume of this is how
often these situations happen with this
so you know I need everybody that's
listening knows when they go too much
okay so we understand that we're not
balancing rikiei we've decided that
there's some things that are important
we've identified those through passion
we have learned to say no to some of the
bad things we've also learned we kind of
touched on it there but embracing
mediocrity also includes delegating
right it does it can be part of both
doesn't saying no you just give it away
entirely and somebody else deals with it
from then on
delegating is in some sense you still
remain involved but somebody else is
doing most or all of the work and of
course that if you're doing that as part
of the the good enough piece what that
means is they may not do it as well as
you would or exactly the same way you
would and then you have a choice you can
micromanage them which means you end up
doing it anyway and they end up
frustrated
all exactly or you can say good in
office so when I started my business now
as a coach and leadership consultant I
hire other people to work for me
sometimes doing psychological
assessments on people perhaps who are
applying for a very senior level job and
the company wants a really good
assessment of you know what's how's this
guy put together or a woman and so you
know us you you do give the assessments
you evaluate the results and then you
write a report so this person who was
working for me would write the report
and he would send it to me because I
cosign it so I always want to see how it
looks and it wasn't really written quite
the way I would write it it wasn't that
it was bad or that was wrong it just you
know the turn of phrase it wasn't quite
the same and I would have done more of
this less of that and at the beginning I
was doing all this redlining and
rewriting and then I thought wait a
minute you know I'm paying this person
to write the report there is nothing
wrong with the report that he's written
it just doesn't sound exactly like a
young golden well that's okay
let it go and it's that learning how to
delegate and let other people do things
their own way to their own standard
that's the art of it and so many people
have trouble with that it's a really
important insight that I hope that a lot
of the people that are listening
especially the young entrepreneurs or
people that have a desire to go into
business that red pill took me a decade
to swallow we used to say me and my
business partner used to talk about we
would an ongoing joke about if you want
a job doing properly do it yourself and
here's the absolute perfect example of
that so I run club nights that's what
I've done for the last fourteen years I
get people drunk in nightclubs and um we
were the directors I've been the
director since I started have founded
the company director of the company for
14 years and me and my business partner
every Saturday for four years without a
break 210 Saturdays in a row until I had
a stomach bug that meant that I couldn't
I couldn't be at work literally had to
be dragged away by it by a
a virus we would turn up 11:00 a.m. at
the club let ourselves in and do stuff
like set up the inflatables because if
we delegated it to someone I knew that
maybe the inflatable would just be off
to the left a little bit and then
there's a particular way that they have
to put the cable ties around the
barriers outside and there'll be a ton
of the guys that work for me that are
listening and thinking yeah I remember
that bit and I remember that bit and I
remember that bit and that took me when
I look back now that was my mid-20s
every Saturday I wrote off the daytime I
never had a Saturday daytime I used to
know off by heart the different radio
presenters that would present on the
radio because I'd know who was
presenting on my way in then who was
presenting while I was in there and who
was presenting his Ella I hate the radio
the radio sucks but my point is that I
sacrificed so much not only of life
where I could have been enjoying life
but that wasn't my highest calling
within the business I could have given
that to any student that could have paid
eight pounds an hour to they would have
got some extra hours out of it and I
could have added value in the business
in some of the places that only I can
but because I wasn't prepared to
relinquish I wasn't prepared to delegate
and let go of control what ended up
happening I ended up wasting four years
of my life sat in a club throwing trying
to throw bits of rope over the top of
Ornan so that we can pull you up an
inflatable and not driving more trade
for the business so that is that's the
example for you there totally you know
one of my clients years ago taught me a
very interesting phrase he was a senior
executive in a bank and he said his
motto was only do what only you can do
now that's aspirational everybody has to
take off the garbage from time to time
do you know what I mean nobody can only
do what they are uniquely qualified or
talented to do but using it as a goal
only do what only you can do is a really
good rule for curating your life or
figuring out what you should be putting
your energy into
and your story about you spending all
this time throwing ropes over things I
mean absolutely classic it's absolutely
right yeah you know this delegation
piece is often a very big issue for
somebody in business who's had a
promotion and you get promoted because
you're really good at what you've been
doing in your job and then you go up one
level and it's the most normal thing in
the world to that you want to continue
doing what got you promoted which is
what you what the former jump was about
except that's not your job anymore and
other people are supposed to be doing
that job now and you have got to get out
of them out of the weeds and up to the
next level where you are overseeing
supervising directing guiding inspiring
coaching and not doing the work yourself
one of the most difficult challenges for
people when they get promoted to a more
senior role relinquishing that control
it is really really difficult yes and
you know I feel for the people who don't
know the sensation it's almost like
quite a mindful activity the mindfulness
gap of when you feel the the tensions so
I've arrived in your body and it sort of
comes up through your stomach and you
feel your shoulders come up and you
almost sort of move forward toward the
thing that you're doing and that's the
sensation that I get sometimes like I
say looking at this website it's kind of
consuming me for the last couple of
weeks with that thing and I can feel
myself and I might it's is it good
enough yeah is is it good enough yeah is
that's fine and that just allows us to
roll forward so I think you've got a
really nice framework there with helping
people to relinquish their time so we've
embraced mediocrity how can we how can
we start to choose and live our
greatness now yes so that's I mean in
many ways for well I was gonna say
that's the fun part except it's not
always fun so first of all figuring out
your greatness is sometimes hard some
people have so many things they're good
at or so many things they love doing
that it's hard to focus it down and you
may say well gee whiz I'd love to have
that problem of being you know great at
17 things but
it's a problem it's a challenge to let
go of things and I think some of us feel
like if I have a talent in this area I'm
obligated to use it and then that feels
like I'm somehow failing myself or
others if I don't make use of this
ability I have but you know Leonardo da
Vinci who was one of the most talented
and and multi-talented people in the
history of the world and even Leonardo
wasn't good at everything wasn't great
at everything you know he made choices
and he did different things at different
times in his life so being aware
figuring out what first of all what is
my talent what am i what am one of my
gifts what am I good at the other thing
that's very real is what's my
opportunity you know am I in a place and
then it's time when I can actually
pursue this because we tend to
overestimate you know the individual's
abilities and and drive and
underestimate the reality that your
context is going to limit you in many
cases or say not now maybe later on but
not right now so why don't what are my
talents what are the opportunities
available to me and what is my passion
what what do I find I'm thinking about
and talking about and longing to do and
you look for the intersection of those
things to figure out what the greatness
is and again for right now so that's a
whole process and it could be quite
complicated and it could take a while to
figure it out and as in my case I mean
what I was working on being great at for
their first half of my career was being
the greatest psychotherapist I could be
which is really hard by the way and
takes a long time and I got to be really
good at it and then I got tired of it
and it was time to reach for something
else and that's what I did
letting go of our past epochs can be
super challenging had a discussion with
tokamaks
who famously founded the frat eyre
literacy genre which is kind of young
bros partying and getting drunk and
stuff like that and that because he was
New York Times bestseller
or three or four times over with that
particular type of book and then he'd
wrapped his identity around in it and he
found it really challenging to become
who he was next you know what you two
beasts a husband a father a family man a
CEO a business and you have these old
labels and these epochs right and
everyone knows everyone that's listening
has got that friend that still stuck in
the identity they were when they were at
school or at college you know oh yeah
it's painful yeah yeah the captain of
the football team you know I mean yeah
what it made it there you go so so
there's there's that identifying the
greatness at this time and then living
your greatness how are you going to go
for it my husband is a musician and he
teaches music students and his
observation is talent absolutely you
need talent but you can predict who is
going to be a really great musician much
more on the basis of their work ethic
their discipline they're willing to do
what has to be done
more so than their talent and you can be
probably a second-rate talent with
first-rate discipline and you're going
to get further ahead than the first-rate
talent with second-rate discipline so
it's it's hard work to be great at
something and you have to you really
have to be willing to to make the
sacrifices to do what it takes to you
know manage your procrastination to
manage your distractibility to stay on
task to stay focused and as I said there
can be great joy in that but it also is
hard work it means not doing other
things that you might also enjoy doing
and again I want to go back to to me
that doesn't mean that this is the only
thing you do that you just you know 24/7
you're working on that not at all
you take your breaks you have some fun
you fool around something when I was
writing my book I was very disciplined
about it because I know that was the
only way it was going to get written I
had chunks of time set aside that this
is what I do and I remember one after
there was a 4-hour chunk I was about two
hours into it I thought you know I just
need to take a little break I'm gonna go
watch television for a few minutes and
two hours later I was still watching
television so that mean that happens
right and the point is at that point I
can beat myself up and say oh I'm such a
loser I'm never gonna get my book done
or I can say I guess I needed to do that
so I did it so tomorrow I get back on
track and I have to really have a whole
chapter in the book called busting loose
which is about the fact that even when
you're a highly disciplined person you
have to cheat sometimes you have to do
the little things that break the rules
and the trick is to figure out what are
the little things not the big black
awful things that are gonna be
irreparable but the little things where
you can dip your toe into mischief and
then get back on track and give yourself
room to do that how do you draw the line
yourself between
a deserved break and pushing a lack of
discipline too far so that you tumble
into undisciplined and start to build
bad habits how do you sell how do you
self-discipline that's you know is it's
a very good question and it's a nuanced
thing because again I I think if you try
to force yourself to be on task every
single minute you're going to fail so we
need to give ourselves some room to fool
around from time to time to do something
silly to waste time look I suppose part
of it is looking and seeing how many
days in a row did I do that
or how many hours in a row it kind of
reminds me you know Weight Watchers
which is the organization that helps
people get to a healthy weight they have
a wonderful saying that it doesn't in
the United States it doesn't matter what
you do on what you eat on Thanksgiving
Day which is a day of overeating it
matters what you eat on the day after
Thanksgiving
the idea being on Thanksgiving Day
you're gonna be what do you feel like
eating that's what the day is for but
the next day you get back on track you
get back on eating the men in a way you
want to eat to be a healthy person if
you use Thanksgiving as an excuse to
overeat for the next three months you're
in trouble if it's one day you're not in
trouble so part of it is looking at that
ability to bounce back to say okay
that's enough of that back to work and
then there are tricks you can use for
example it can be you look at a task and
it looks so big and so daunting it's
like oh my gosh I can never get that
done and one of the tricks is to chunk
it down into manageable pieces you know
take your website for examples I mean
the whole building of that website I'm
sure was a massive project so you know
if you had found yourself having
difficulty starting with that you could
say well what's the first thing I need
to do maybe I need to reserve a website
so do that piece that's all you know
then I'll think about the next step and
and then and by the way reward and
congratulate myself as I accomplish each
of the steps along the way it's much
more manageable than looking at the
whole big mountain and saying oh my gosh
it's too much I guess I'm yeah just
gonna go watch some more cartoons on
television or something like that so so
that chunking piece is a piece that we
have learned really enables people to
stay focused and to stay on task when we
need to there's no next action next
physical action which is ever too
difficult right like given enough time I
could walk to Mars if you gave me like a
couple of million years I could walk to
Mars because it's just one step after
and I'd have to be a couple of
bioengineering acts happen to me first
my point is that it you can always take
one more step right but if you were to
say to someone I need you at walk to
Mars it's it's a little bit a little bit
challenging okay so we've got ourselves
to the to the stage where I was starting
to choose and live our greatness what
about curating our workplace now well so
then I started to think about leadership
and
as a business leader it seems to me you
have two responsibilities one is to
curate your own life to utilize your
energy in a way that you are putting
your best energy into the things that
matter the most to you into the
organization that you lead and by the
way curation is not a purely selfish
process where all I care about is you
know what's good for me it also we were
social people we're in a social context
we are thinking about other people at
the same time so so curating your life
as a business leader but the second part
is looking at the environment you're
creating at the messages that you are
giving to the people who work for you
and thinking about am i leading in a way
that enables and facilitates them to
curate their lives and you know in many
cases the answer is not so much what
some of the ways that people often
business leaders often create a place
isn't a simple one is I'm a night person
I get a great idea at 11:30 at night and
I fire it out to my people at 11:30 at
night or 1 o'clock in the morning and
I'm the boss right and people feel that
then there's an expectation that they
should respond to that you know there's
a really simple hack you know in an
Outlook which is the messaging system
that I use you can stick to a delivery
schedule so we love it that's right
schedule send you know so I can have my
ad I'm not an that person by the way but
if I were and I have my 1:30 in the
morning know a flash of insight I write
the email and I get it sent it known or
whenever my people are gonna be around
you know and and by doing so I send the
message that I want you to curate your
life I want you to have a reasonable
organization of your energy and I'm
gonna take a minute to tell one of my
favorite stories about this because I
think it's really important my father
was a Holocaust survivor he escaped from
Germany to England in 1939 and spent the
war in England and right after the war
children who had been incarcerated in
the concentration camps were brought to
England for rehabilitation and there
were a number of centers around England
where these traumatized children were
brought to bring them back to health and
they needed to find people who spoke
German Polish or Yiddish because that's
what these children spoke so my they
reached out to the community of my dad
who has zero training in this
volunteered to be one of the counselors
at one of these rehabilitation centres
and they had one day off a week when
they worked at the rehabilitation centre
and the director of the centre told them
you are not allowed to be on the campus
on your day off you may not show your
face around here because he knew that
these people were so dedicated to the
work that they would be there seven days
a week and they would drop from
emotional and physical exhaustion
so he made a rule you couldn't come in
on that day that to me is an example of
a business leader saying I need to think
about your well-being not just my own he
might have said yeah the kids need you
seven days a week so come on in and he
did not so that kind of thinking about
helping your people to manage their
energy so that they can bring their best
and they get the breaks they need
whether it's taking their vacation days
whether it's not sending emails in the
middle of the night whether it's saying
hey you know it's summertime we're all
going to quit work at three o'clock in
the afternoon on Friday whatever it may
be to me that is part of a leaders job
to help others curate their lives if
you're not a business leader how can you
contribute to that environment let's say
that you're just an employee
or a worker how can you contribute to
that it's harder because you don't
really have the power that the leader
has and you may be working in an
environment that doesn't encourage that
kind of curation I guess my first
thought is you quietly do it yourself
you know you don't have to be telling
one of the things I say about media core
by the way and being just good enough is
when we figured out what you're gonna be
just good enough on don't tell people
just quietly be good enough they will
notice in most cases you don't have to
go announcing by the way I'm going to be
mediocre on how well I shine my shoes
just just don't care you know so in the
same way I think you can quietly curate
your life without necessarily making an
announcement about it but it's difficult
I mean if you're working in a place that
has these unreasonable expectations for
attendance length of time productivity
that's very difficult and I think in
many cases you're wise to find another
place to work now I agree the the
garyvee hustle and grind mentality is
never one that's really sat super well
with me it's not resonated massively and
I think that a big part of it is that I
know I think everybody knows in the
heart of hearts that the person who's
able to go very very hard for four or
six hours per day will outperform the
person who's still in the office at 3
a.m. because the person that's still in
the office at 3 a.m.
isn't working that hard they just sat
there they got their phone out there on
YouTube like the number of time so last
Run Club nights and a lot of the guys
that work for me a students at
university and a lot of the time they'll
come in around about the exam period and
they'll do a full day in the office of
revision but during the full day in the
office
I've seen them they'll be on snapchat
for half an hour they love this I'm like
dude you could have been in and out of
here in three hours right if you'd left
your phone at home if you'd put
RescueTime or some other sort of website
blocking app on your computer and you
just nailed it like if you'd gone so
this is another Cal Newport deep workers
and where he says that work done equals
time times intensity so you can do three
hours at a ten or you can do ten hours
at a three and it is hard don't get me
wrong the higher levels of discomfort
the high levels of intensity have a lot
of discomfort with them because you
don't get the little dopamine hits
you've also got to be super super
focused but the more that you try and do
that the more that you cultivate a
an atmosphere of excellence where you
are focused on the things that you're
supposed to do the easier it comes
thereafter and you get greater
satisfaction from it no one no one wants
to spend ten hours a couple of days
before a project deadline doing 50
percent intensity gray vanilla quality
work you don't want that it doesn't make
you feel satisfied but you know the days
that you go in when you some only
absolutely crush it five hours in and
out everything's done you've got the
evening to yourself like that
that is where work feels satisfying
right I absolutely agree and I you know
I think yeah I mean you said it and it's
that satisfaction that comes from Sprint
and recover and the productivity it
comes from that it's just that that's
where that's a winner exactly we've got
workplace side can we can we curate a
home as well because there's you've got
a you know I gotta be a mother a father
a brother whatever the house may
whatever it might get right yes um I
think I think the same principles apply
both in terms of making a choice about
what kind of energy I bring home and do
they get my leftover you know 25 percent
fairly irritable itself or do I bring my
best self to my home and if so how do I
do that there are lots of other pieces
to that I mean I what we're hearing a
lot a lot in the States and my guess is
that it's true in in in the UK as well
as teenagers who are driven like maniacs
I mean the cause you know the ideas you
have to get your kid into the best
University so that then they can get
jobs with the top firm in New York and
and and then they can you know be
wealthy and live happily ever after and
and if they don't get a perfect score on
this exam the rest of their life is
gonna unravel and and I see young people
teenagers you know expected to get top
grades active in 17 different career
extracurricular activities doing good
work in the community mean impossible
demands and and crumbling under the
pressure you know if that's your
kid you're not doing a good job curating
as a parent and you need to get real
about what are the one two or three
things that you want to help this kid
focus on and the rest of it can be just
good enough or I'm not doing it at all
and yes we want our children to have a
good work ethic and we want them to have
persistence but part of that is
sometimes the kids saying you know what
I'm one of my son's decided he was gonna
take gymnastics for a while
he took he's a really good athlete he
took two classes he came and said I hate
it I don't want to do it I said fine
don't do it anymore just because you
signed up doesn't mean you have to do it
I mean you hate it there's a lot of
things in life you have to do even when
you hate gymnastics is not one of them
[Music]
so you know letting your kids quit stuff
letting your kids do something just well
enough is as part of this as well so
that's some of the home curation stuff
that I think it's really important I get
that so final thing is there anything
left to say about how discipline in the
liberation link together because I like
I like the idea of the Sprint and the
recover I think that's a really good way
for people to balance their energy but
is there any more on discipline and
liberation well I think I touched on
this but it is an important point I
think there you simply cannot be
disciplined about everything in your
life all the time nobody has nobody will
nobody can and there's a certain
pleasure in breaking the rules even the
rules I've set for myself and so
learning how to do that I talked about
there's the white zone where I'm
behaving in an absolutely exemplary
manner I'm being the Galle that I really
want to be and the kind of person I want
other people to be and there's the black
zone where I'm doing something that's
really destructive I'm stealing from my
employer I'm driving drunk I'm doing
things that are really wrong and in
between is the gray zone where I just
can't just being a little bit
bad you know I drink two martinis
knowing that I'm gonna get silly or I
eat chocolate cake when I'm really
trying to you know get lean and have
been physically fit I committed myself
to exercising five days a week and you
know what I'm taking a week off I'm not
doing a little bit bad I tell a slightly
off-color joke I mean again using
judgment and and dipping my toe and
there's something about that little bit
of mischief that little bit of
naughtiness that feels good and then we
can go back to being that admirable
individual that we're trying to be most
of the time how many of us have this
rigid conscience inside that we
developed from when we were really
little which is like it's either black
or white you're either a good boy or
you're a bad boy and what I'm suggesting
is that adults we have room where that
little place in between where I'm not
being a good girl or a bad girl I'm
being a little bit naughty girl
and we need to visit that place in order
to then gain the energy back to go ahead
being the person that we really want to
be I love it I love it I think it's
really cool I like the idea of people
being able to be their own
disciplinarians and also getting that
liberation from it the delegation stuff
again like that's such an important part
been such a crucial side of me allowing
myself to do more of the stuff I want to
do I mention I have a cleaner and it's
like I could I clean my house yet during
lockdown I have but does she do it
better than me absolutely does it mean
like do I don't enjoy it it's fun at the
moment cuz there's novelty attached but
and as I said everything else like
delegate down all of the stuff that you
can't do and if you're in a position
where delegation isn't an option as you
said look toward that what is the
minimum viable effort or the minimum
viable mediocrity that I can bring to
the table here that allows me to work on
what I want and the kind of final thing
that I really like of how it all pieces
together is that
you talked about how you want to go
incredibly hard you want to work in
these sprints if you do all of the steps
before which ensures that the thing that
you're doing is close to your highest
calling close to the passion that you
genuinely feel it won't feel like work
you will want to lose yourself in
writing the book for four hours because
that is what you're compelled to do yes
exactly that's how it comes together and
and you get that exhibit where the big
pieces are hanging in the middle the
necessary but not huge pieces are kind
of off in a side room somewhere you know
and the stuff that doesn't matter is
back in the storeroom maybe for another
day there we go you did it look curating
your life will be linked in the show
notes below if it sounds like this is
the sort of thing that you are
struggling with ending the struggle for
work-life balance I couldn't recommend
it more it's really really cool it's
very actionable I think you've done a
great job with it Gail if people want to
find out a little bit more well why
should they go anything to plug online
sure my website that's brilliant of
course Gail golden consulting.com please
come and visit me you can leave a
message if you like and yeah the book
those are the two main places fantastic
thank you so much for your time you know
what to do if you enjoyed the episode
like share and subscribe or give me a
message where ever you follow me at
Criswell x I will link Gail's fantastic
website as I'm sure it is and the great
curating your life in the show notes
below Gail thank you thank you it's been
a pleasure I really enjoyed it
[Music]